for almost 60 years the CBI has claimed
to speak for business but that Voice May
soon fall silent after some of Britain's
biggest companies rushed to end their
association with the lobby group The
Crisis began with reports of serious
misconduct including an allegation of
rape against a senior manager at an
office party on the Thames now a second
woman has alleged she was raped by two
CBI employees working at an overseas
office triggering a flood of companies
to suspend or end their membership
including NatWest Virgin Media BT
AstraZeneca Ford and meta owners of
Facebook the companies we're talking
about today they have deep values and
they have leaders who follow through on
that their values within their own
workplace I think after us point it
becomes untenable for them to remain in
a situation where there is a string of
very very serious allegations
the CBI has already sacked its director
General Tony danker for unrelated
misconduct he says made him a scapegoat
now the organization has effectively
Frozen day-to-day business and signaled
the CBI as we know it may be over
in a statement the CBI board said we
have taken the difficult but necessary
decision to suspend all policy and
membership activity until an
extraordinary general meeting in June at
the egm we will put forward proposals
for a refocused CBI to our membership
for them to decide on the future role
and purpose of the organization
John Lewis is one of dozens of household
name businesses that have walked away
from the CBI and the government has
already said it won't talk to the lobby
group while investigations are ongoing
without the confidence of its members or
the ear of ministers the CBI can't make
the case for business and plainly can't
promote best practice its future is in
serious doubt
the members who've called the cbi's fate
into question will decide if it still
has a voice in the summer Paul Kelso Sky
News